it must have been obvious to you that
putting this up was going to lead to Mrs
vardy being abused wasn't it a
scriptwriter would have struggled to
dream this up
I've never been in a court I've never
been in a legal case before
this is the first time publicly I've
ever spoke about this now Agatha
Christie lives again with court
transcripts from the multi-million pound
libel trial set to be brought to life
for West End audiences the dialogue is
very robust there's kind of costumes
wigs there's these really fantastic
dramatic moments and already like this
trial had all the ingredients of a great
drama the story of course began back in
2019 when Rooney broke the internet with
this post announcing she'd left a trail
of fake story breadcrumbs to work out
who was selling stories on her to the
sun and it was dot dot dot Rebecca vardy
insisting her name was unfairly dragged
through the mardovadi lost a fortune
making Rooney come to court to prove it
her lawyers transporting everyone back
to the World Cups of yesteryear in a
time when wag culture was both
aspirational and monetizable
on top of what was a stupendous waste of
money it is faintly ridiculous that not
only is there a theater version taking
place here there's also a TV production
in the worst a reminder of a bygone
newspaper age of tabloids being tipped
off this case almost calling time on
that particular era of celebrity culture
from successful business owners to model
influencers to property developers
things couldn't be more different for
the partners you'll find supporting
England at the World Cup in Qatar but if
it looks like a leak and it sounds like
a leak and you even use the word that it
is more likely than not to be a leak
no well the case and now the play
certainly lifts the lid on those murkier
tabloid times should we feel a little
guilty about dining out on the details
this is the women telling their story in
their words in a way that we haven't
seen yet I don't think it's quite
exposing for both of the women I would
hope that an audience wouldn't just be
laughing at them and kind of thinking
haha isn't it funny these two Wags going
at it exposing but more for what privacy
and celebrity means in modern Britain
Katie Spencer Sky News